[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في مجوز من قناه
الجزيره اعلن المتحدث باسم العمليه
السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر يوسف تاجيل
التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي الذي كان
مقررا اليوم وقال ان تاجيل جاء بسبب عدم
التوافق اطراف الاتفاق الايطاليه على بعض
القضايا واكد المتحدث ان اجتماعا سيعقد
اليوم السبت في القصر الرئاسي يضم الاطراف
المدنيه والعسكريه والاليه الثلاثيه
لتحديد موعد جديد لتوقيع الاتفاق النهائي
افاد مراسل الجزيره باصابه فلسطينيين
بجروح حرجه برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عند باب السلسله في البلده
القديمه المحتله وافادت مصادر بان قوات
الاحتلال دفعت بتعزيزات مشدده واعتدت على
عدد من المعتكفين داخل المسجد الاقصى
[موسيقى]
وحضرت رئاسه الفلسطينيه من تصعيد السلطات
الاحتلال في المسجد الاقصى المبارك وقالت
ان هدفه توتير الاجواء وجر الامور الى
مربع العنف في شهر رمضان ودعم متحدث
باسميه حركه فتح منذر الحايك كل من يستطيع
من الفلسطينيين التوجه الى المسجد الاقصى
والمرابطه فيه لحمايته وقال الحايك انما
يحدث في الاقصاص استفزاز لارهاب المرابطين
في الاقصى تمهيدا للسماح للمستوطنين
المتطرفين باقتحامه بجهاته قال النطق
باسميه حركه حماس حازم قاسم انما حدث عند
ابواب الاقصى جزء من الحرب الدينيه التي
يشنها الاحتلال على شرف الفلسطيني وان
الاحتلال يحاول ان ينتقم من اهل القدس بعد
وصفه بالزحف الكبير للجماهير الفلسطينيه
في باحات المسجد الاقصى امس خلال صلاه
الجمعه
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الجنرال مارك ميري ان روسيا فشلت
استراتيجيا وعمليا وتفشل الان تكتيكيا
ايضا واضاف في لقاء مع موقع ديفنس ان
اخراج القوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا مهمه
عسكريه صعبه للغايه لكنها ليست مستحيله
واكد انه من غير المحتمل ان تنجح القوات
الاوكرانيه في اخراج جميع القوات الروسيه
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا العام
في جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي لمناقشه خطه
روسيا نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
بيلاروسيا اتهم روبرتو نائب والمندوب
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن روسيا بالتلاعب
بموت وصفه بشبح الصراع النووي لكسب الحرب
في اوكرانيا
في المقابل انتقل المندوب الروسي في مجلس
الامن مواقف الدول الغربيه ازاء قرار
روسيا نقل اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه الى
بيلاروسيا وقال ان الخطوه لا تنتهك
التزامات موسكو الدوليه فيما يتعلق بعدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
قال محامي الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بانه اتفق مع المدعي العام في منهج
على الا يتم تقييد يديه ترامب بعد تسليم
نفسه لمواجهه الاتهامات وكان مراسل
الجزيره قال انه جرى الاتفاق بين الادعاء
العام وهيئته الدفاع عن ترامب على ان يسلم
نفسه للتحقيق يوم الثلاثاء
انتهى الموجز